je m'appelle alité à mon histoire est
vraie
je suis une créature solitaire
je n'ai ni enfant ni soeur ni frère ni
par an autrefois j'ai eu un mari
qui peut dire si le destin existe
mais dans le grand bassin d'istanbul
j'ai choisi un souvenir
jeu-là d'or je suis persuadé qu'il a une
histoire intéressante
[Musique]
qu'elle vous souhaitez vous que chaque
sens qu'est ce que votre coeur désire le
plus
j'aurai une question que peut-on faire
avec trois voeux
vous verrez
[Musique]
n'existe aucune histoire qui parle de
voeux et qui ne soit pas une mise en
garde
nous avons tous des désirs même s'il ne
nous apparaissent pas clairement mais
c'est votre histoire et j'ai hâte de
voir où elle mène au voir comment elle
pourrait finir
bonsoir il va rester un moment
safer le faisons tous disent avoir
rencontré
autre info
ça y est j en veux
[Musique]